ما يقارب بين ثلاثه ارباع سكان العالم في
سن العاشره وما فوق يمتلكون هاتفا محمولا
حسب التقديرات يعاني ما يقارب من مليار
و300 مليون بالغ من الذين تتراوح اعمارهم
بين ثلاثين لتسعه وسبعين عاما في جميع
انحاء العالم من ارتفاع ضغط الدم وبما ان
الهواتف المحموله تصدر مستويات منخفضه من
طاقه الترددات الراديويه لهذا ربطتها
دراسات بارتفاع ضغط الدم بعد التعرض لها
لفتره قصيره على مدار 12 عاما حلل فريق
بحثي صيني بيانات اكثر من 200 الف بالغ
تتراوح اعمارهم بين 37 و73 عاما ولا
يعانون من ارتفاع ضغط الدم مع اسئله تتضمن
ما اذا كانوا يستخدمون مكبره صوت او جهاز
بلوتوث من دون استخدام اليدين حول ساعات
الاستخدام والتاريخ العائلي المرضي كل هذه
الاسئله في النهايه اكتشفوا ان الاشخاص
الذين يقضون اكثر من ست ساعات على الهاتف
اسبوعيا لديهم خطر ارتفاع ضغط الدم بنسبه
25% مقارنه باولئك الذين يقضون اقل من خمس
دقائق فقط في اجراء او استقبال المكالمات
الهاتفيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات